how do you find your purpose in life
what do you do if you do not know what
your passion or your purpose is in life
no matter how old you are Sean first of
all love your music bro love number two
this is my favorite question
give your fans and many of mine are
quite Young and the biggest mistake that
people make in their youth is they don't
taste enough things you've got to try
different things how do you know if you
love architecture or if you love music
or entrepreneurship or video games if
you've never played them never try them
you might be amazing at drama you might
be the greatest actor in the world
because you don't think it's cool you
never try it because you're a big time
athlete the easiest way to find your
passion is to go try stuff go taste
things please my friends in your teenage
20s and 30s years please try as many
things sign up for clubs hang out with
friends that do different things and
most of all own what you actually love
even if it's not cool now